you're a part-time youtuber
you have stuff on youtube i guess yeah
yeah but
if you've seen my youtube it's mostly
it's very
it's uh it's not it's character they're
not high effort content
yeah uh but do you like any particular
youtubers um
i i could just recommend like stuff i've
seen so a good matter the gotham chess
is live
um i really like uh st louis chess club
uh danielle naraditsky and uh john
bartholomew those are good channels but
is there something you can recommend no
all of them are good
you know the best recommendation i
could
as a godmother um
purely how much did he pay you to say
that no so the thing about that
is that i haven't really i have so i can
tell you i've never watched any of his
videos from from start to finish yeah
i'm not like i'm not the target audience
obviously
but
i think the only chess
youtube video that my dad has ever
watched from start to finish is agamater
and
he said like i watched one of his videos
i wanted to know what what it was all
about
because i think aguamata is like
the same strength as my father or maybe
just a little bit weaker like
1900 or something my father is probably
about 2 000.
and my father has played chess his whole
life uh he loves he absolutely loves the
game it was like that's the only
time he's actually sat through one of
those videos and he said like yeah i get
it i enjoy it so that's the best
recommendation
i could give that's
the only channel that my father actually
enjoys
this is hilarious i talked i talked to
him before this to ask him if he has any
questions for you and uh he said no just
just do your thing you know what no he's
so careful he wouldn't uh do that he did
mention jokingly about
uh evan's gambit i think is that a thing
evan's gambit is some weird thing he
made up it might be an inside joke i
don't i don't know but he asked me to
well anyway yeah i didn't even get um
it's something yeah he made up i
didn't even realize that he placed the
evans camera like he plays a lot of
gamut star wait evans gambit is a thing
yeah yeah that's the thing like that's
an old opening from the 1800s uh captain
evans apparently invented it why would
he mention that particular one yeah
something hilarious about that one
i don't know
i i don't think i've ever faced the
evans gambit and uh
in a game i feel like both of you are
trolling and trolling me right now
but i mean he's
he's played a lot of other gambits
maybe this is the one he wanted to to
mention so this maybe this is called the
evans gambit as well
but i just know it as like the two two
g4 gambit maybe this is the one like
this one he has
this one he has played a bunch
uh
and he he he's been telling me a lot
about his games in this line he's like
oh it's not so bad
and i'm like yeah but you're upon down
yeah but i can i can sort of see it i
can sort of um i can sort of understand
it and he's like
he's proud of the fact that nobody like
told him to play this line or anything
he came up with it
you